on va revenir tout de suite sur les deux
sujets du jour emmanuel macron à l'école
et le témoignage d'eric zemmour après
son agression alors hier on vous a parlé
de la polémique au sujet de l'agression
dont a été victime eric zemmour est
aujourd'hui on voulait revenir dessus
puisque le journaliste et polémiste est
revenu sur cette affaire hier soir sur
ses news on vous resituer d'affaires
jeudi dernier une vidéo publiée sur les
réseaux sociaux a fait énormément de
bruit
on y voit eric zemmour suivi est
interpellé par un individu en pleine rue
regardez petit récap regardez c'est un
ouais c'est l'esma précédent et vous a
fait plaisir en tout cas ça a coupé il y
avait des gouttes de pluie qui tombait
sur mon téléphone j'ai pas pu fournir la
vidéo jusqu'au bout je peux vous dire il
a goûté un mollard allen spears et
quelques instants plus tard ce même
individu prétend avoir je cite cracher
un mollard sur le journaliste et hier
soir dans l'émission face à l'info sur
ces news avec christine kelly
eric zemmour est donc revenu sur cet
incident regardez ce qu'il a dit vous
allez nous dire ce que vous en pensez de
ce qu'a dit eric zemmour sur cet
incident datant des biens surtout sa
réaction et il a dit bien sûr au micro
de christine kelly et de ses nous
regardent pour s'afficher pour se mirer
dans le miroir des réseaux sociaux on
est prêt à faire n'importe quoi et donc
a insulté et violenté et c'est moi je
vous avoue que je m'en tiens
mon analyse historique vous savez vous
m'avez déjà entendu dire ça je pense que
ces six l'amour à kayes puisqu'il
emploie lui-même le moc c'est comme ça
qu'ils les appels sont le bras armé
d'une guerre de civilisations sur notre
sol d'un djihad permanent et qui chasse
et pourchassent les infidèles
vous savez ce qui m'est arrivé c'était
embêtant pour moi mais ça arrive tout le
temps tous les jours depuis des années
depuis des décennies à des millions de
français alors arrivé depuis des
décennies à des millions de français
c'est ce qu'a dit eric zemmour s'est
tout de suite la première partie d'un
autre quart d'heure sans fil puisque
après on aura emmanuel macron à l'école
fait partie d'une gueule quart d'heure
son fils
voilà il ya toujours pas de dingle au
bout de trois jours ils ont toujours pas
compris les séries donc eric zemmour
donkey revenus donc voilà sur ce qui
s'est passé et on va revoir les les
excuses de l'agresseur dans l'instant
parce qu'il a donné aussi son avis sur
les excuses de l'agresseur qu'est ce que
vous pensez de ce qu'a dit eric zemmour
jean michel maire moi je suis pas
fondamentalement en désaccord avec lui
sauf qu il
il se résume à sa situation sauf que
pour moi ce qui lui est arrivé c'est le
symbole d'une violence généralisée pas
seulement contre dix les infidèles et
cetera
ça s'est un peu de mise en place voilà
parce qu'il les aime l'ambiance est sont
des deux côtés voilà mais c'est une
violence généralisée contre les femmes
aussi sont ils sont victimes dans la rue
deux insultes sexistes léger ça si c'est
une violence généralisée syrie c'est
vrai que c'est pas là que le bât
d'accord bon valérie benaïm non non ce
qu'imaginer c'est qu'ils trouvent une
confirmation de ses idées dans son être
dans cette agression
c'est ça qui me pose problème c'est ça
et moi j'ai pas envie qu'il utilise sa
propre pour tenir une sorte de martyrs
de ses idées de sa cause au moi je suis
totalement opposé à ses idées mais peu
importe je suis pour le dialogue à
propos disputer pour converser avec lui
et pour le débat donc voilà et ce qui me
gêne moi c'est dans
on dans sa prise de parole c'est de dire
vous voyez dans sa navigation
c'est l'explication de tout ce que je
vous dis et pourquoi j'ai raison et
c'est ça qui me gêne
alors alors il est revenu aussi parce
qu'on va voir les explications de
l'agresseur pour expliquer son geste
regardez et s'était excusé et on va voir
ce qu'a dit eric zemmour des excuses de
la grâce à regarder d'abord les excuses
de l'agresseur regarde c'est que j'ai
mal agi j'aurais pas dû agir de cette
façon j'ai pu le blesser et choqué
beaucoup de monde et je regrette
vraiment mon geste est par contre je
n'ai agi au nom d'aucune communauté et
contre aucune communauté
alors c'est aussi dans cette vidéo qui
s'excuse pour son geste qu'il regrette
énormément
regardez vous allez voir ce qu'a dit
eric zemmour sur les excuses de son
agresseur dit qu'elle voulait savoir si
je crois à ses excuses
monsieur zemmour alors est-ce que vous
pensez que la france sur l'âge répond
pas en prison mais pourquoi je vous
répondrai pas aux questions mais vous
êtes tellement extrême la tiens monsieur
je ne vous me je ne suis pas une vache
enlever ça déchire ils se sont trompés
henri je voudrais qu'on est les excuses
du jeune homme voilà les excuses du
jeune homme et après on va voir ce qu'a
dit eric zemmour des lexus d'hommes et
regarder d'abord ses excuses regardez
les excuses de la greffière
alors regardez donc ce qu'a dit eric
zemmour sur les excuses de l'agresseur
regarder si elle voulait savoir si je
crois à ses excuses je vous réponds non
je pense que qu'il a d'abord il a été
lui aussi violemment insulté sur les
réseaux sociaux si j'ai bien compris
d'ailleurs je remarque que dans cette
histoire c'est les réseaux sociaux qui
font tout vous avez remarqué les médias
traditionnels de n'en parle pas les
réseaux sociaux se font là là une
réalité c'est très intéressant quand on
les critique tout le temps deuxièmement
ses excuses je pense que c'est c'est du
bidon
je pense que c'est un avocat de gauche
qui lui a conseillé de faire ça parce
que il a bien vu surtout les crachats
entend de coronavirus
ça peut ça peut aller chercher loin
alors eric zemmour que vous avez pensé
de la réponse d'eric eric naulleau est
ce que ce que nous avons c'est de la
réponse d'eric zemmour quand ces thèmes
là dessus ce qu'ils ne savaient pas
financer il s'était expédie rapidement
la question des excuses parce que là je
suis entièrement d'accord avec eric
zemmour s'est complètement bidon ce ce
pauvre titre i said on essaye d'échapper
à deux choses l'accusation
d'antisémitisme et 10g page et coupe la
communauté et puis il essaye d'échapper
un autre traité auquel on pense pas
c'est vrai que par temps d'épidémie
cracher sur quelqu'un ça peut être
considéré même comme du terrorisme
donc voilà j'expédie ça après il ya une
chose qui me dérange mais ça me
dérangera toujours chez ces examens et
je le comprends dit chaque semaine je le
combats c'est que tout s'inscrit dans un
système de pensée préalable c'est un
idéologue
je ne partage pas son idéologie mais en
même temps je suis je lui ai dit dans la
dernière fois que nous avons débattu de
ce sujet je suis horrifié je suis
exaspéré par le déni des gens qui ne
veulent pas voir qu'il ya un problème
avec une frange de la population vous ne
venez pas le mot racaille je
l'utiliserai passe aussi par une franche
délinquante qui se croient tout permis
qui pensent qu'elle peut agresser les
gens ils sont vantés sur les réseaux
sociaux
donc je suis entre le rejet du déni et
le rejet des deux sapins thèse d'eric
zemmour pourquoi dit-il un avocat de
gauche un gant d'après l'avocat aurait
conseillé à ce type de 10 par action
pourquoi parler d'islam aura kylie cela
n'a pas grand chose à voir dans cette
histoire il serait donnée pas du
prophète
donc voyez je suis entre les deux
j'essaie d'être un homme raisonnable par
les temps qui courent c'est très
difficile alors il est revenu aussi sur
sur un autre point qui a beaucoup fait
parler
c'est l'appel qu'il a reçu du président
de la république emmanuel macron que
rappelé eric zemmour les deux hommes ont
échangé environ 45 minutes et eric
zemmour regardez a tenu à en reparler
dans face à l'info avec christine kelly
il m'a d'abord tout simplement
[Musique]
demandez comment ça allait quoi tout
bêtement et puis la discussion s'est
engagée et en fait on s'est rendu compte
que nos désaccords étaient profonds et
qu'il fallait un peu de temps pour les
pour les élucider donc nous avons nous
avons parlé longtemps
est ce que ça veut dire cet appel qui
nous à vous êtes passé d'ennemis à
adversaires enfin peut-être peut-être
qu'il considère lui que je suis un
adversaire mais pas un ennemi et moi
aussi
alors qu'est ce que vous en pensez de sa
wii jean michel maire de choses j'en ai
un peu marre des gens qui font de la
merde sur leurs pareils qui fournit de
vidéos d'enfants a su tant que ça et qui
après ses excuses non c'est pas tes
s'excuse réfléchi avant de faire des
vidéos qui sont vraiment les vidéos qui
sont insultantes agressivité tard et 2
c'est pas le pardon mais je le reçois
quand quelqu'un d'une saloperie un poste
de téléphone
il réfléchit la nuit l'eau mais l'appel
dans excuse moi je pense parce que tu es
du tueur et le tu dis pas rappelé que
jusqu'en t'as vu que sur les réseaux
sociaux ça provoque 4 et est contre toi
et du fou tu réagisses disent qu'ils
s'insèrent ok on va oui oui la crème
woippy chez rigourd c'est loin d'être
analysé mais comment dirais je sais pas
qui tout à l'heure
ce qui me fait chier mais parce que eric
zemmour fait ça mes toiles exergue alors
que j'aimerais c'est tous les jours et
toutes communautés confondues que cette
violence elle est dans l'art dans les
rues et je trouve que c'est inadmissible
que au mètre de moi et ça me parait que
c est pour ça que c'est toute la vie
dans toutes les rues de toutes les
villes qu'elles aient abiola et müller
de suite email et le beau gosse est
différent le wagon solitaire à la barre
mais on ferait mieux de s'occuper
vraiment de cette violence au quotidien
tous les jours et non pas à me parler
kalt chef de file de l agression ouais
d'accord c'est vrai aussi c'est vrai
aussi mais voilà alors on va voir ce
qu'on pensait téléspectateurs sur eric
zemmour eric zemmour témoigne la voilà
les noms ils n'ont pas lancé de deux
sondages mais c'est pas grave
merci à vous il fallait à 6 voilà oui
j'aimais le témoignage d'eric zemmour
après son agression j'ai aimé à 53% j'ai
pas aimé
à 47% voyez c'est la première fois je
crois où il ya un sondage vous verrez
que zemmour sort avec la majorité c'est
incroyable